hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to vanish now I said that I
would finish it and markiplier keeps his
promises or maybe not I don't know I
don't know what I do but I said that I
was gonna beat it and I got really
really really close last time so I'm
gonna revisit this I know this game oh
so well now and if I can just get lucky
enough if I can just get lucky enough to
find the boiler room right after the
generator room I will be fine but let me
crank up the volume again I got the
volume like super duper duper loud this
time but I am NOT gonna stop until I pay
that I don't know why I'm yelling but
just bear with me let me do my own thing
while I do this and you all just sit
back and relax I need to find the water
pump room let's keep going straight
because that never failed us before oh
the old familiar places oh how I have
missed this wonderful place nothing
tells me to go this way I can smell it
deep in this pungent sewers here oh no
wait that's the smell of piss and it's
coming from my pants what the hell is
going on here all right you
randomly-generated beast you beauty you
wander his horror game of delights I
really go that way I believe you I know
it's far too early to actually find any
monsters so I'll be fine
up until I get to the point where I get
to a boiler room and or a generator room
oh by the way I oh by the way I actually
on those as test for a dialect um trying
to find trying to find where people live
based on how they say certain things and
there was a differentiator between room
and room so it's a thing people say it
that way
well everyone that says room
right in the comments below that you're
right and everyone else is wrong a la la
radio busted I was real close on the end
of one of the patents the last time I
play this I was real close to getting to
the end but alright okay my vision went
tunnel II but it's nothing to worry
about just a light one out I'm a little
jumpy my characters a little jumpy I
don't need to worry about it well anyway
I got real close to the end but they
didn't actually make it to the end it
it's nothing it's nothing there's not a
thing oh there's a hole in the wall
that's good I love a place to run to
okay you're just digging with me now
you're just digging with me all right
yeah else here whispering is that is
anyone here whispering like seriously
whispering that that's not supposed to
happen I don't remember that definitely
heard something Earl over this way hey
well if you text oh I don't believe you
feel my name Phil I'm not exist sure I
remember my name's fillers are my Larry
is that Larry or that Phil nope dog dog
don't know just shut up you shut your
dang ass up oh it's it's back to the
beginning
wait a minute there's no way that I
could have lived I can't
no don't run hey oh oh oh look at this
but oh look at its bite did you guys see
it but I thought but ha ha ha
okay alright come over here and I had
the best of luck going this way we use
old gloss stick nope now look your baby
number me everybody bunch of lies
you put your dirty dirty lies the bunch
of Lies but just stupid dirty lies nope
ah you're not real
I know you're not real nobody lies just
like everything else in this game it's a
bunch of lies Todd WEP of luck okay oh
oh I thought that was gonna be something
okay anybody value not that way let's go
this way
okay all right okay okay go on give me
the damn generator of I found the water
pump rum no give me another one I gotta
admit that if I don't ever actually run
or sprint right into him I should be fun
he's got me if there's a thing you over
there don't be so scared man don't be so
scared
there's nothing to worry about down here
nothing no whoo okay so why why why
okay oh good one loogie can I to get
another clue flim and flam flam whatever
your name is
Bluebird smitty werben jaegerman jensen
I use that too much sweetie oh no
another one I don't care forgive me much
light it makes me feel better makes me
feel okay okay no no that way there's a
bad way
give me another one damnit I don't know
how many close sticks that I have in
stock does a little bit I guess
could you get out of my ear please did
you get out of my ear oh come on you're
not helping me I'm going in a circle I
didn't even think is possible to go in a
circle in this game come on
calmly quietly calmly quietly calmly
quietly calmly quietly doable quietly
calmly quietly go this way
okay alive oh don't you be over there
you [ __ ] you bastard you beautiful mole
man
another one I don't care if it does not
help oh look it's dingy don't ever look
back don't run the whispers like don't
follow the pipes don't ever run don't
ever run I think I'll need a run if
they're chasing me but yeah whatever
don't follow the pipes what I mean there
are only ever pipes although I've never
really looked are there no pipes oh
don't run oh okay will you lund I hear
something circling around my head I
don't think I've ever been a lot ok
looky-looky-looky Kiki hey ok I'm ok I'm
not running now following the pies I
kind of in following the pipes but there
are nothing but pipes I'm not but pipes
not pipes for your butt
I think I might be out of glowsticks
oh it changed it changed it changed
again and now I'm stuck in permanent
whoa come on Fat Bob hope you'll okay we
are good - good - no no you tickety
bastard you turn around go away go away
oh look at your little button okay
so I'm not doing too good but I'm still
gonna beat it
look let's see I'm gonna go to the hole
I'm gonna go the hole this baby it'll
leave me somewhere else
give me the dingdong damn keys I need to
find the generator room okay what's with
this hole is this hole messing with you
okay it is over to eBay okay good it's
just a stray lie oh come on what with a
piece of favors well that day Alissa's
was it I know it listens cuz it's blind
just checking it okay I've never been
allotted lawyer my entire life but I
gotta be this game okay going anyway
blue
oh don't know oh no I don't know ladies
and gentlemen boys and girls of the
YouTube space I don't know I don't know
what do I don't know anyone for me like
my brain is going much more insane the
longer that I stay here did I just piss
myself I may have I don't know oh look
another node no and but dead what does
that mean Jeff smitty werben jaegerman
jensen oh no you're talking a little bit
of nonsense here come on just give me
the damn generator I can make this I
know I can I know that I I know that I
can haha oh that's gonna run why did I
run I'm gonna friggin idiot oh my okay
I thought I was dead like 100% I'm Otto
is dead
I thought I was going to die okay is
this building okay all right I'll take
it
I'll take it don't take it nothing shut
up huh Bera
that symbol doesn't that mean that see
you over there I see you keep walking
going that way
can you walk by me oh I know it's that
way I was so close I know the generators
that way okay ah damn it
let the flip dickin beginning is he
still coming after me cuz I want to go
that way okay
alright okay I think he gave up no no
I've seriously never been alive this
long I don't know how I feel alive but I
am and that's okay I'm hearing noises
that I've never heard in my entire life
and I seem to be screaming oh yeah I see
dizzy Oh Rob give me the keys give me
like ding dong damn keys ok get him
oh you stay over there you stay over
there oh [ __ ] damn it god I always for
all god damnit
no I'm too close what I died Oh be a
good boy god damn it I've already gets
good I've gone again I got bad luck on
that last one I didn't find my hairs all
good yeah that more represents my
attitude at this point at this juncture
that is my you never mind you know what
let's just do this let's finish this
[ __ ] how did I die did I just go to
psycho is that what happened I just went
to insane in the membrane
I don't know I think that is what
happened like I ran out of time my my
heart just right in my chest just good I
do notice that the longer I play this
game the louder I become like this as a
baseline my bass level voice just keeps
going up okay alright
all I saw something I saw something okay
I'm still want to echo something - it's
saying don't follow the pipes like I
don't know what that means
cuz there's always pipes
there's always fight and I got really
bad luck not finding what I needed to
find I don't know I don't know but
either hey ah come on gosh dig it it's
like it doesn't want me to win
how can everyone else play this game and
win it but this game just constantly
decks my plate I want to win okay I'm
running screw you guys I'm an expert at
this game you're not maybe you are I
don't know you won in I haven't don't
shut up shut your pal
hey your beautiful faces don't believe
[ __ ] I don't know what I'm saying yeah
alright okay relax everybody relax
everybody take a deep breath and relax
I just did relax gosh dang it oh so it
has begun I found the keys I was so
clear classy clothes okay all right
arrow pointing this way that's the arrow
from my good friend smitty werben
jaegerman jensen that means that I need
to go this way shut up you diabolical
Beast in the darkness okay you're right
there all right then I'll just go this
way that if you stay over there shut up
and if you stay over there I'll go this
way
I got like it's like 15 minutes until
your brain just melts in your heart
bursts inside your chest oh that's how
much time I got to beat this is there
something wrong yeah yeah maybe mark
bars go a little crazy
in this game may be large but I losing
it mind it's a little bit no one has had
this much trouble playing this game than
me oh come on no no no no no you walk
your little booty over that way and shut
up with the whispering okay seriously is
it just me or is everyone luckier
playing this game than me I'm pretty
sure that's how it is because there's no
way there is no way that I have this
much bad luck
this game is specifically designed so
that it knows when it's being played by
Marga bar and I'm sprays bit all over my
screen but I don't care okay
here's the great there's spit everywhere
all over my screen come on
let's peek is it still a dead end I
don't know it was a little dead end ha
ha ha shut up I don't care anymore I
don't care it's just let me win for one
what's it my life happy with ah come on
come on this is unfair
is it unfair I hear whispering from
behind this ball yeah doc what did I do
god damn it I want to win let me wear
him hey who's go left
follow the light wanna win I want to win
so badly
wait well boy let me win
any meenie miney mo
did I buy no baby I'm go
anyway mo god damn you Hank
or I'm Hank you're Larry you're franker
donk or mantra plonker flunk or [ __ ]
dr. buck ride oh no I'm just going in a
circle god damn it you're just sending
me in a gosh-dang circle I know you are
you son of a [ __ ] game oh come on why I
have run into Gore dead ends and anyone
else why why why you do shut up why do
you do this to me oh oh come on follow
the pipes follow the pipes follow the
pipes what does that even mean I don't
know what you're talking about follow
the dingdong damn pipes Wow Adele I
didn't even have anything stay baby
never mind
and why it was like in the middle of a
breath there you dick
ha ha ha Stiller I'm gonna a dead end
going to dead end
ahh come on [ __ ] it let's anywhere
that's same dead end
why won't you let me win won't you let
me win just for God's sake let me win I
play you for way longer than I should
and you don't let me win I've weighed
you for hours and hours and hours this
damn game I can't win
now I'm gonna be by the gun shot line
why you have relay haywire Ave it's
gonna be a dead end is it it's gonna be
a ding-dong damn dead end it's gonna be
a dead end
no you don't do that to me you don't do
that to me no why why are you doing wait
a minute don't follow the pipes they're
all pipes Oh pipes you douche they're
all pipes there aren't any not pipes cuz
they all have pipes
I don't know anymore
I just don't know oh great I've been
playing too long now and then I'm gonna
go psycho bonkers crazy I'm not gonna
make it to the end because I don't have
enough time anymore
shut up just tired of your ball give me
some I mean anything oh well that's not
what I wanted
been watching no damn note ah done I'm
done
I can't do it I can't beat this freakin
game I can't do it I'm done I'm done
subjecting my heart to this game my
throat from screaming I'm done I'm done
I can't be banished I can't I can't do
it it's impossible for me for me for you
guys oh yeah perfectly fine you can do
it you got no problems you can beat it
on the first try me no I've been playing
it for hours and I'm not even
exaggerating literally hours there's
footage of me playing this that you guys
haven't seen that I've been playing it
for hour so I can't beat it it's a
simple game I can't beat it won't let me
win I'm done okay all right that's the
end of it vanish Oh baby